ينضم الينا الان من دير البلح مراسل
الجزيره هشام زقوط هشام كيف تتابع هذه
التطورات عند معبر رفح لتوزيع المساعدات
الانسانيه على النازحين على الحدود مع مصر
في اي سياق
[موسيقى]
تاتي المساعدات سواء المساعدات الغذائيه
او حتى الت والكثير من المساعدات والادويه
الطبيه دخلت خلال ال0 يوم لكنها بكل تاكيد
لا تكفي لحاجه قطاع غزه في ظل هذه الاوضاع
هذه المساعدات
هي تقدم من عده دول واغلب هذه المساعدات
هي عباره عن مياه عباره عن دقيق عباره عن
مواد تموينيه وفي جلها تذهب الى وكاله غوث
وتشغيل اللاجئين الونر التي تقوم بنقلها
من شاحنات مصريه الى شاحنات فلسطينيه وهذه
الشاحنات الفل فلسطينيه تقوم بالدخول من
خلال معبر رفح بالدخول الى قطاع غزه يتم
فحص وترتيب هذه الشاحنات بعد دخولها الى
الجانب الاسرائيلي الذي يقوم بفحصها
واليوم هو اليوم الاول الذي يقوم الجيش
الاسرائيلي بفحصها في معبر كرم ابو سالم
التجاري المغلق منذ بدايه هذه الحرب
الاسرائيليه دخلت هذه الشاحنات الى معبر
كرم ابو سالم ومن ثم دخلت الى قطاع غزه
دخلت الى قطاع غزه يتم تفريغ
واعاده تحميلها الى الش الطينيه في
الساحه التابعه للجنه اعمار قطر ومن ثم
تدخل الى قطاع غزه عند دخولها الى قطاع
غزه منها ما يتم توزيعه خاصه التابع لبعض
الجمعيات والمؤسسات الخيريه ومنها ما يذهب
الى وكاله غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين الانر التي
تقوم بدورها بتخزين هذه المساعدات في
مخازنها الخاصه ومن ثم وفق اليه توزيعها
الى المواطنين الدقيق يوزع الى المواطنين
كل المواطنين وفق اليه حسب عدد افراد
العائله حسب ما تحدثت به الاونروا ومنها
ما يتم توزيعه في مراكز الايواء وهي مراكز
كثيره تابعه لوكاله غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين
الاونروا وفيها اكثر من مليون فلسطيني كل
مدرسه تابعه للاونروا ربما فيها اكثر من
10000 فلسطيني من النازحين من مدينه غزه
من شمال القطاع من المناطق الشرقيه لقطاع
غزه وهذه مراكز الايواء منتشره في كافه
محافظات قطاع غزه لا سما في المناطق
الوسطى والجنوبيه هذه المدارس فيها
النازحون ويتم توزيع المساعدات
اليهم المواد الغذائيه التي تصل يتم
توزيعها فقط على النازحين في مدارس الانرو
اما الدقيق فيوزع على كافه المواطنين
الفلسطينيين في كل المناطق لكن الاخطر من
كل ذلك وربما الاصعب ان المساعدات ممنوعه
من الوصول الى مدينه غزه وشمال القطاع
وهذه المساعدات مقتصره فقط توزيعها على
المناطق الوسطى والجنوبيه وبالتالي
الاوضاع تزداد صعوبه يوما بعد اخر في تلك
المناطق في مدينه غزه وشمال القطع